le 7 février laurent gbagbo doit être
libérée est restée qu'un pauvre dans les
rues d'abidjan
le procès en appel de laurent gbagbo
fait naître l'espoir de le voir rentrer
au pays parmi des partisans de l'ancien
chef de l'état
son parti le front populaire ivoirien
attend avec impatience le second passage
de son ex leader devant la cour pénale
internationale la cpi est un homme
soutenu un homme aimé par son peuple
un homme qui a réclamé par la population
de côte d'ivoire qui inspire beaucoup
d'impatience aujourd'hui de le voir
revenu dans son pays
c'est de montrer à la cpi que la côte
d'ivoire réclame le président n'aura pas
beau gars n'a pas d'autres en janvier
2019 la cpi à qui tu l'ancien président
de toutes les charges portées à son
encontre
à savoir son inculpation tant que
coauteur indirect de quatre chefs de
crimes contre l'humanité sous forme de
meurtre de viol et violences sexuelles
d'actes de persécution et d'autres actes
inhumains
il est libéré mais assigné à résidence à
bruxelles dans la tente du procès en
appel le 7 octobre dernier l'avocat de
gbagbo dépose une requête auprès des
juges pour que soit levé les contraintes
qui lui sont imposées mais en face les
avocats de la côte d'ivoire estime que
la clôture du dossier qui impliquerait
le retour de l'ancien président encore
d'ivoire serait un facteur de graves
désordres cette décision c'est d'abord
l'échec de la vérité il restera toujours
qu'il y a eu plus de 3000 morts et qu'on
ne saura jamais qui est responsable de
ces morts pour comprendre cette décision
il faut voir qu'elle s'inscrit dans une
phase d'affaiblissement de la cpi loin
encore d'un retour au pays natal
laurent gbagbo restera soumis à un
contrôle strict jusqu'au verdict du
procès en appel au plus tôt en juillet
prochain
il faudrait également que les juges
concluent leur délibéré une procédure
qui devrait durer jusqu'en octobre
prochain date à laquelle les ivoiriens
voteront pour élire leur nouveau
président